ferais-tu si je mourais papa pleurerais-tu
car je pense que je ne m'arrête jamais
Oswald je
comprends pourquoi Rick est celui qu'ils arrêtent c'est
vraiment dur veux-tu rester avec
toi jusqu'à ce que tu t'endormes ça va
aimer aimer aimer aimer aimer aimer
Je sais que les choses ont été difficiles pour toi
depuis que Barbara est décédée pour toi et
pour les filles, une de mes dynamites.
Je combats
Blue est l'endroit où je veux être quand je
vais de bas
tu vois maintenant toi seul pourquoi puis-je forcer le
Rani à se marier mais à
rester coincé
si je suis un escroc
nous mon  dieu mon triste le sécurisé à l'école
dans ce cas tu peux m'appeler mademoiselle
Cunningham tout va toujours mal
nous nous inquiétons des choses qui arrivent
nous allons piéger
juste fait de briques bien juste pour que tu
penses que tu Michael pour me retenir